j'ai besoin d'amour j'ai besoin de
poésie j'ai besoin d'alexandrin j'ai
besoin de VOUS allez-y je vais démarrer
ce tour des poèmes par
ordre décroissant
âgée alors Jean-Marie merci c'est moi
poème en Alexandra vous me dites
monsieur que j'ai mauvaise mine qu'avec
cette vie que je mène je me ruine que
l'on ne gagne rien à trop ce prodiguer
vous me dites enfin que je suis fatigué
oui monsieur je suis fatigué mais je
m'en flatte j'ai tout de fatigué le cœur
la voix la rate je m'endors épuisée je
me réveille là mais grâce à Dieu
Monsieur je suis chez Cyril Hanouna
j'ai compris
c'était un poème justement parce que
c'est beau et c'est magnifique
[Applaudissements]
je sais que le 8 mars tu as bien eu la
trouille la failli me déglinguer avant
que je me rouille j'étais tellement sûr
que je verrai tes cours c'est mal écrit
simple je suis rentré
je priant tous les saints pourvu que le
PSG soit à nouveau vaincu car c'est ma
dernière chance de me faire bouffer le
mince je vous laisse j'ai
[Applaudissements]
il y a un parti pris
mon cher Cyril
non déjà là non gloire à l'homme qui
valait 3 milliards
[Rires]
merci de me laisser mettre des coups aux
chroniqueurs autour de vous ceux qui
sont dénués de talents et qui compensent
en vous suçant
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
sauf peut-être ce crevard de Delormeau
on va passer à allez on va passer à
Bénin moi j'étais très premier degré du
coup
[Applaudissements]
toi tu as vraiment écrit ton poème
et des fous rires pas d'écran tu sais
toujours nous faire sourire ton humour
est vif ta réparti à serrer les moments
les plus sombres tu nous fais oublier
avec toi pas de tabou tu oses tout avec
toi pas de limite tu n'es pas de ceux
qui prennent la fuite tu es le maître de
l'improvisation était vannes font vibrer
toute la nation tu es mimiques tes
grimaces sont devenues légendaires à la
télévision tu es un phénomène
incontournable et ton show et mémorable
merci Cyril pour ces moments de
complicité ces émotions que nous offre
sans jamais compter
[Applaudissements]
il y a pas
allez je vais enchaîner maintenant
juste après
niveau
[Rires]
il est 18h50 tu peux repasser vers 21h
c'est dans la bonne humeur
je ne sais pas si c'est ton parfum ou
ton charisme qui font que quand tu
débarques j'ai des poils qui servissent
mais une chose est sûre mon Baba mon
petit corps tu ne laisses pas froid j'ai
tant rêvé être ton coloc de partager un
lit et de finir en cloque
tu sais que je t'aime comme tu aimes le
paddle alors laisse-moi rien qu'un soir
être ta petite cagole
[Applaudissements]
on veut tous te hein
j'espère bien mon pote depuis quelques
années tu es ma lumière oh merde tuer
les feux xénon de mon camion mon guide
ma boussole ma lanterne te voir danser
en tournant chaque soir me donne envie
de t'emmener en tournée laisse-moi
conduire sur tes genoux laisse-moi faire
pouet pouet avec tes yop
au niveau des règles
prenons la 104 direction poteau combo
que je monte sur ton poteau
direction jouer à jouer aux jeux à ce
qu'on joue ensemble
[Applaudissements]
si je suis sur tes genoux c'est normal
il était terroriste
[Applaudissements]
quand tu veux t'arrêter là
qui reste
et Kelly girardine
je te sens pas je me sens pas mon gars
j'hésite non mais j'ai bien aimé
vraiment c'est pas nul qui peut y aller
tu peux y aller
ou tu vas dire
roi de la darka beau comme un lavabo
belle comme on hirondelle
[Applaudissements]
il y a tes intuitions il y a tes visions
il y a tes fulgurances c'était drôle de
danse il y a tes coups de sang et tes
opposants tes amis fidèles étaient fous
rires rebelles il y a tes costards
étaient compétentes il y a Baba il y a
Hanouna dans le PAF partout sans un jour
de répit et toujours à dire à son cher
public mille mercis
[Applaudissements]
je la mets numéro 1
je la mets numéro 1 de la mes numéros
c'est tout le monde a bien bossé après
voilà après c'était quand même voilà
franchement
[Applaudissements]
tu aimes ton public tu leur dis merci
tout ça c'est de l'amour
[Rires]
on ne sort jamais parce qu'on a trop
sucer jamais sachez
ça va c'est ça se passera toujours comme
ça alors toi c'est pourquoi c'est pour
toi c'est pour faire quoi c'est une
adaptation de Baudelaire donc j'ai juste
changé un peu donc pardon j'ai pas non
plus quand on a pas le talent
Cyril tu es mon roi je suis ta reine
tu sais qui c'est je vais arrêter là tu
arrêtes que ça finit c'est Baudelaire
n'insulte pas la poésie je suis loin de
toi je suis blême dans mes nuits nos
coeurs sont là comme ton pain préféré la
fougasse
les Français t'aiment car tu entends les
gens dans la rue aussi ne serait-il pas
temps que je te bouffe le cul
merci beaucoup
[Applaudissements]
je suis désolé c'est pas nul merci non
je te jure dans la rue je te bouffe le
cul
riche
non j'ai pas compris
je crois que c'est pas le plus connu de
Baudelaire
t'emmerde pas t'emmerde pas tu emmerde